Alright, so, you asked unfortunately what happens when the,
the learner is now a part of this. Now
the learner doesn't have that advantage that the teacher
had of knowing what the actual answer was and
therefore being able to show specifically what's irrelevant and
show what's relevant. So, what could the learner do
to try to learn about this? So again, remember
that there are 3 to the k possible hypotheses, and
if it could use the 20 questions trick, it could do this in log base 2
of 3 to the k, which is the same as K times log base 2 of 3.
Which is you know, worse than what we had. It's this is, this is larger than
1. But it's still linear, it's still linear
in K. So, but can we actually do that?
>> I'm going to say yes.
>> I don't think we can, so can you help me figure out how that would go?
>> Oh, I was just going to assert it, then hope you would tell me.
so, how would we do that? Well, we, we, the trick we did before is, we, we
tried to find a specific question we could
ask, such that we would eliminate half the hypotheses.
>> Indeed. But it's not clear how you could even ask such a question. Yeah,
so, so just to do this as a thought exercise, I have a hypothesis in mind.
>> Okay.
>> And you can ask me anything you want, and I will tell you
true or false. But you're going to have a very painful time finding it.
>> Yeah, but that's just because I'm human.
Okay, so I need to find a question where,
of all the hypoth, so I have all the possible 3 to the K hypotheses. I want
to try to come up with something that's
going to eliminate a third of them which is
just going to be hard for me to do because I could write the program to do this.
>> I'm not sure you could. I think, at the moment,
there's well, because I didn't choose my hypothesis at random. I chose
a specific hypothesis. Though I guess I could have chosen at random
from a subset, and you would have still had a hard time finding
it. But let's, just as an exercise. Throw out, give me a, give
me a x1 to x5, and I'll tell you what the output is.
>> Okay, 00001. Or actually, you know what? All zeros.
>> Okay, all zeroes, the output is zero.
>> Oh, that's what I should, that's not what
I should have done. I should have. No, no.
>> That's okay, I won't count that one.
>> [LAUGH] Can I just give you like, maybe 3
to the k of them and you'll not count any of them until I get it right?
>> Well, that's the problem, right? Well, not 3 to the
k, but if you, if you, you know, make 2 to
the k guesses, do, you'll be okay. But you'll also have
looked at all possible inputs. So that's not really that interesting.
But in particular, the example that I'm thinking of, you're going
to have to guess almost this many just to get a
positive example. So almost everything that you throw in is giving
almost no information. Because saying no doesn't really tell you very much.
>> Yeah that's what I was thinking. Well, what I was
thinking was I need to find one where the answer is yes.
>> Exactly, and I made it so that it's going to take
you exponential time just to find one. Once you've found that one,
then you're, then you're home free but it's going to take you,
you know, you essentially have to
enumerate all possibilities before you find one.
>> Okay, 0 0 0 0 1, okay? 0 0 0
1 0. And you're going to tell me that 0, 0, 0,
>> There's only
one pattern that gives a one.
>> Right. Exactly. And you're going to, because every single one
of them is relevant. And I'm going to have to look.
>> Two of them are negated. This is the only pattern
that gives you a one. Now once you have found that
and you know that that's the only one, now it's easy.
You can just read off the equation. So, what's the equation?
>> XN not two and X3 and X4 and not X5.
>> And that is the, that's the equation and
you are not, you're not, there's no as a learner
you are not going to be able to find that, right?
Because it's just a needle in a haystack until you hit it.
>> Yeah, so it's, it's going to take me exponential time, but
it, but remember we're not worried
about time. We're worried about sample complexity.
So remember the cheat that we have here. The cheat that we
have here is that I know all the hypotheses and what they say.
>> It doesn't help you.
>> Yeah it does, because the hypothesis, cause every hypoth, well no,
that's not true. I'm thinking the wrong thing. I'm sorry. I'm cheating,
you're right. I'm cheating. I'm, I'm acting as
if we have the example you had before.
>> So this constrained-ness is really, it's very frustrating, right?
Because the question that you really want to be able to
ask, you can't really ask, right? You want to be
able to ask a question that, that takes the hypothesis class
and split it in half and. Well maybe you can,
maybe you can nearly do that. But it's still going to
be, oh no sorry, that would make it linear. I'm
sorry, let me say that again. You'd like to be able
to ask a question that, that splits this
hypothesis class in half, but unfortunately almost all of
your questions give very little information. Just knocks
out a couple of the possible hypotheses, and so
it ends up being 2 to the k kind of time, not time but samples before you
can get a handle on what the hypothesis
is. So, it is harder for the learner too.
>> Right, so when the learner does it you have no reason
to believe one hypothesis over the other. You've got all of them.
And so in order to figure it out, no it kind of
has to be that way because otherwise it is still linear. So,
this is bothering me, because if what you said is true, then
why does 20 questions work? Why do i ever get log, log 2.
>> Right. So we'd like to be able to ask questions. So I, so
here, let's play this game now. You think of a, a formula. And I'm going to.
>> Oh, wait, you. I know the, the answer is, is that the 20 questions
is still the optimal thing to do, given
that you know nothing. So that, that log base
2 is kind of an expected answer. But sometimes
you'll do much worse, and sometimes you'll do better.
>> No, in this particular case, if I could ask you more general questions. I
can do this in, in with the, you know, linear in K. So the questions that
I'd like to ask you are things like, is X1 in the formula, yes or no?
[LAUGH] Is X1 positive in the formula? Is X1 negative in the formula? I can just
fill in these boxes by asking the right questions.
>> Right.
>> But, but those questions are not
in our constrained set. And it's the constrained
set that matters here. And our constrained set
is, in this particular example just really harsh.
>> So, and there's no way to approximate that, right? So
I can't say, okay, so the first question I want to ask
is x1 positive, negative, or absent? So, if I looked at all
the hyp, if I looked at all the hypotheses I could do
that by asking, now it's very hard to do, because
there's no direct way to ask that question. The only
way to ask that question is, I have to try.
Well, I have to try all possible exponential cases to know.
>> Yeah, 'because we're constrained to only ask queries that
are data points, right? So give me the label for
this data point. And that's not really the same as
is the hypothesis you're thinking of having this particular property.
>> But as soon as I get a one,
I know something.
>> Soon as you get a one, you're in a much happier place.
So, in fact, if we didn't, if we had conjunctions of literals without negations
>> Mm-hm.
>> We'd be in a much better situation, because then you could, your first
question can be, you know, one one one one one one. You know the answer
has to be one, or the formula's empty. So then you're, you're basically off and
running, but the fact that there can
be negation in there means that most queries
really give you useless information.
>> So, so Michael, okay, so you've depressed me.
You've basically said this is really hard to do, to
learn because I think that we've convinced ourselves, at
least you've convinced me that until I get a one,
until I, I, I get a positive result, I
can't really know anything. And eventually I will get one
if I can just do an exponential number of samples,
but then my sample complexity is exponential, and I'm sad.
So what you're basically saying is, I'm sad
sample complexity makes me a bad person, and there's
really nothing I can do to learn anything
or get anything good out of my learning process.
>> That seems like a very sad way of saying it.
>> Yes, is there a happy way of saying it?
>> There isn't a happy way of saying that. But
there is, there are other questions that have happier answers.
>> Okay, like what?